GOOD MORNING THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW
IN SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA. BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO.
SERVAN SAYS TRIAL CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI. KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY.
EIGHT MEN.
FLORA.
FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES.
CARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN MERCY.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
REYES IS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD.
SPEAKER
FIRST THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN
SESSION PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY TO
THE FLOOR
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR TODAY'S A VOCATION.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB OSHITA. REVEREND
OSHITA.
TO THE A RECEPTION WILL FOLLOW.
COMMEMORATING HE SEVENTY SIXTH
ANNIVERSARY. OF EXECUTIVE ORDER
NINE OH SIX SIX.
IN MEMORY OF THOSE WHOSE LIVES
WERE UPROOTED AND INCARCERATED.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE A GIFT THAT I
WAS GIVEN ALMOST FIVE DECADES
AGO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
QUIET REFLECTION.
IN THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES I
VOLUNTEERED TO HELP EVERY
WEDNESDAY AT THE HAMILTON SENIOR
CITIZENS PROGRAMS SAN FRANCISCO.
BACK THEN THE SENIOR PROGRAM WAS
COMPRISED ENTIRELY OF BC. FIRST
GENERATION JAPANESE AND JAPANESE
AMERICANS
MOSTLY WOMEN.
DURING OUR AFTERNOONS TOGETHER.
I WOULD TRY TO ASK THEM ABOUT
THE FORCED EVACUATION AND THE
INTERMITTENT.
IT WAS A SUBJECT ARE SECOND
GENERATION KNEE SAY NEVER EVER
TALKED ABOUT.
WHEN MY PERSISTENCE WORE THEM
DOWN TO MY DISMAY THE TALK
LATELY ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE.
OVER THERE WAS BASEBALL SUMO WE
LEARNED TO KNIT AND SO.
I WANTED THEM TO SHARE THEIR
SUFFERING AND RESENTMENT FOR THE
INJUSTICE INJUSTICES THEY HAD TO
ENDURE.
I WANTED TO BECOME THEIR
ADVOCATE AND BECOME ANGRY AND
INDIGNANT FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY
WOULD NOT.
ONE AFTERNOON. WHEN AGAIN I
PRIESTESSES WITH MY QUESTIONS.
A WOMAN I WILL ALWAYS CONSIDER
MY ADOPTED GRANDMOTHER MRS KEOGH
HUMANO.
PULLED ME ASIDE AND QUIETLY
SAID.
SO KNOW CAMPANA HOW NICE YOU ARE
MORE YOU HAVE A NICE SITE.
STOP TALKING ABOUT THE CAMP.
WHICH YOU DON'T SIR BECAUSE. OF
COURSE IT WAS HARD.
THEN SHE TOLD ME NOT TO PICK UP
THE PAIN AND HARDSHIP THAT WAS
NOT MINE.
HE SAID THE CAMP WAS HER
HARDSHIP.
AND THE ANGER STOPS WITH HER.
SHE SAID THAT IF SHE LIVED WITH
HATE SHE WOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO LIVE HER LIFE.
THEN SHE WARNED ME.
IF I PICK UP THIS PAIN AND ANGER
IT WOULD POISON MY LIFE.
SHE USED THE WORD POISON.
WE WHO ARE PART OF THE
GENERATIONS THAT HAVE FOLLOWED.
HAVE BEEN GIVEN A WONDERFUL
GIFT.
IT IS A GIFT FROM ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE ENDURED THE HUMILIATION AND
INJUSTICE.
THAT WAS EUPHEMISTICALLY
REFERRED TO AS
CAMP.
FOR THEM WE RECEIVED THE GIFT OF
NO ANGER.
EVERY MINORITY COMMUNITY. HAS
EXPERIENCED INTOLERANCE AND
OPPRESSION.
TO THOSE WHO HAVE ENDURED SO
MUCH TO THE YEARS.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE THAT
GENERATIONS THAT HAVE FOLLOWED.
ARE FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
SACRIFICES.
SACRIFICES THAT WILL NOT BE
OVERLOOKED.
OR TAKEN FOR GRANTED.
NOW MORE AND.
BUT KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
I INVITE YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE WHICH WILL
BE LED TODAY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON.
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART READY
BEGAN.
I PLEDGE
.
YOU MAY BE SEATED. WE MOVED OUT
OF READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY FEBRUARY EIGHTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE A. M.
ON WORLD LAURA FRIEDMAN IS.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS OF THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE EVER GOT INTRODUCTION
AND REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
THE ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN TODAY'S JOURNAL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW SOME.
BONTA HOLDEN RISK
O'DONNELL TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. AND ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BONTA QUIRK SILVA AND SHALL TO
SPEAK ON IN THE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TO THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
IF YOU COULD PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING TO THE ASSEMBLY A
GROUP. OF PARLIAMENTARIANS FROM
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
PARLIAMENTARIANS.
YOU PLEASE STAND UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS.
HER AND MEMBERS THERE'S A GROUP
IN THE GALLERY OF SIGNIFICANCE
TO
THE SCIENTISTS WHO WERE HERE
VISITING THE CAPITOL TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND. HOW THEIR SCIENCE
CAN BE APPLIED TO?
POLICY AS WE MAKE IT AND I
WANTED REDUCE SARAH BEGAN TO ITS
WHO IS ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
AND SHE IS SHE WILL BE DEFENDING
HER DOCTORATE. THE END OF THIS
MAY SO I SHOULD SAY SOON TO BE
DR AGAINST THIS.
AND HER WORK HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH A NUMBER OF LOCAL WATER
AGENCIES TO.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BEST
MANAGE GROUND WATER AND ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT RUNOFF AND OTHER
SUPPLIES TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
MANAGE OUR GROUNDWATER AND USE.
WIDE VARIETY OF OF RESOURCES AS
SOURCE WATER AS OPPOSED TO JUST
RUNOFF.
HE'S ABOUT TO COMPLETE HER PHD I
THINK IF ANY OF THE COMMITTEES
TO DEAL IN WATER ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMEONE VERY VERY. TALENTED AND
CAPABLE THERE SOMEBODY YOU MAY
WANT TO TALK TO BUT I WANT TO
WELCOME.
SOON TO BE DOCTOR BAGASSE USE
AND ALL OF THE STUDENTS ARTISTS
WHO ARE HERE TODAY WELCOME THEM
TO THE CAPITAL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS
.
FROM MISTER MULLINS HOUSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO TO RISE TODAY
AS THE MEMBER WHO REPRESENTS IS
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT. A CAL
TECH I RISE TODAY.
JOINING WITH.
MY COLLEAGUES ARE COLLEAGUES.
SO REMEMBER QUIRK AND OBERNOLTE.
BECAUSE IT'S OUR HONOR.
TO HAVE TWO PROFESSORS WHO
RECEIVE THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
TEAM NOBEL PRIZE IN PHYSICS.
FOR THEIR WORK AND DISCOVERING
GRAVITATIONAL WAVES.
DOCTOR VERY BEARISH.
AND DOCTOR KIP THORNE SALT
HUNDRED YEAR OLD MYSTERY FROM
ALBERT EINSTEIN'S THEORY OF
RELATIVITY.
THANKS TO THEIR AMAZING WORK.
THE LEGO OBSERVATORY DOCKET
DOCUMENTED ON FEBRUARY ELEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE FIRST
GRAVITATIONAL WAVES.
TO EVER BE RECORDING.
PARIS INNOVATIVE LEADERSHIP IN
FLORENCE THEIR RADICAL
BREAKTHROUGHS MADE POSSIBLE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF LOOK LIKE GO.
AND THE DETECTION OF
GRAVITATIONAL WAVES.
LAST OCTOBER THEY BECAME THE
THIRTY SEVEN. AND THIRTY EIGHTH
CAL TECH PROFESSORS AND ALUMNI
TO BE AWARDED THE NOBEL PRIZE.
AS A RESIDENT OF PASADENA. I AM
FASCINATED INSPIRED BY CELTICS
DETERMINATION TO PUSH THE LIMITS
OF HUMAN DISCOVERY.
AS THE CALIFORNIA I'M PROUD THAT
SUCH RENOWNED SCIENTISTS CALL
OUR STATE HOME.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND HONORING DR
PARRIS AND DOCTORS OR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
COLLEAGUES.
I MONITOR RISE FOLLOWING THE
RECOGNITION OF THE.
RESEARCHERS WHO HAVE.
VALIDATED THE THEORY OF
GRAVITATIONAL WAVES.
TO HONOR.
SOME FOLKS IN OUR GALLERY UP
HERE TO MY LEFT.
A WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL SCIENCES
TECHNOLOGY DATES BACK TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
WHEN I WAS CHIEF COUNSEL THE
ASSEMBLY FINANCE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE.
IN THIS HOUSE.
IT WAS CREATED BY. HR ONE SIXTY
TWO TO. TO PROVIDE A SOURCE OF
OBJECTIVE ADVICE
FROM CALIFORNIA'S BEST
SCIENTISTS A RESEARCH
INSTITUTIONS ON POLICY ISSUES
INVOLVING SCIENCE.
I HAVE A LONG PERSONAL INTEREST
IN SEISMIC ISSUES AND I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW MANY TIMES I'VE
GONE TO.
CONFERENCES.
WE HEAR FROM FOLKS BRING.
DISCUSS THE LATEST OF THAT
SCIENTIFIC FIELD. AND ALWAYS
THEN THE QUESTION OF HOW DO YOU
BRING THIS
THESE INSIGHTS TO BEAR ON PUBLIC
POLICY MAKING.
AND SO THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
SIZE OF TECHNOLOGY WORKS.
TO BRING THAT THE SOURCE A
SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
TODAY WE'RE JOINED UPS UP THE
GALLERY TO MY LEFT BY CHARLIE
KENNEL. SUSAN PACKWOOD AMBER
MACE JAMES SWEENEY JUDY SWAIN
AND SARAH BRADY.
I WELCOME YOU HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HISTORY IN THIS
INSTITUTION.
BRINGING THE SKILLS TO BEAR IN
THE PUBLIC REALM.
AND I WE KICK OFF THIS WEEK.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY WEEK.
TO.
BRING THIS LEARNING TO BEAR ON
OUR PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES.
DURING THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
WHERE WE ARE IDENTIFYING GRAVITY
WAVES AND WE HAVE IN THE FUTURE.
SO THANK YOU HONOR TO HAVE YOU
HERE PLEASE WELCOME OUR GUESTS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WERE GOING BE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
ITEM ONE PASS TEMPORARILY.
ITEMS THIRD TWO THROUGH SIX PASS
AND RETAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING TO ITEM
SEVEN CLERK WILL PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY BY SOMETHING NUMBER
O'DONNELL AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA PORTS DAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
ACR ONE SEVENTY WHICH DECLARES
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA PORTS
DAY.
IN FACT YOU HAVE A PORT WE HAVE
REPORTED EVERY DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
YOU GET THINGS YOU BUY. AND YOU
MOVE THE THINGS YOURSELF.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE MOST
PRODUCTIVE SYSTEM A PORTS IN THE
NATION INCLUDING THREE OF
AMERICA'S LARGEST CONTAINER
PORTS. AND A DIVERSE SYSTEM OF
SPECIALTY PORTS.
WITH MAJOR FACILITIES FROM
HUMBOLDT BAY TO SAN DIEGO BAY
OUR PORTS ARE CRITICAL GATEWAYS
TO THE STATE'S FREIGHT.
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
PORT ACTIVITIES EMPLOY MORE THAN
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND GENERATE AN
ESTIMATED NINE BILLION DOLLARS
AND STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE
EVERY YEAR.
OUR POLL PORTS ARE ALSO ON THE
CUTTING EDGE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP.
AND LEAD THE NATION AND IN
DEVELOPING ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY PORT OPERATIONS
AND REDUCING HARMFUL EMISSIONS.
THESE EFFORTS HAVE RESULTED IN
REMARKABLE AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS OVER THE LAST
DECADE AND HAVE LARGELY BEEN
ACHIEVED ON A COOPERATIVE BASIS
WITH THE GOODS MOVEMET.
INDUSTRY.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE
THESE EFFORTS AND ALSO WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
PORTS ARE ABLE TO MAINTAIN THEIR
COMPETITIVENESS IN THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST
JUST CALIFORNIA PORTS DAY.
AND ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIANS TO
LEARN ABOUT THE TREMENDOUS
BENEFITS PORTS BRING TO OUR
GREAT STATE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
OKAY THE CLERK WILL OPEN UP THE
ROLE.
CO AUTHORS.
THIS RULE IS OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
IT'S RULES OPENED CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION
.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES THERE ARE SIXTY
TWO CO AUTHORS ON THE MEASURE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SIGNIFY BY SAYING.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE MOVING BACK TO ITEM ONE
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN A SEVEN
BY SOME THE MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO VOTER
REGISTRATION.
I'M SORRY TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
ITEM ONE A MOVING BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I'M O'DONNELL FOR HIS GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED EDITORS OFFICIALS FROM
WHAT OF THE TWO PORTS IN MY
DISTRICT THE PORT OF LONG BEACH.
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH HAS MADE
TREMENDOUS IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT IN RECENT YEARS AND
AS DEDICATED TO CONTINUING THIS
MOMENTUM QUICKLY. AND
AGGRESSIVELY THROUGH THEIR GREEN
LEADERSHIP.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND
CURRENT LONG BEACH HARBOR
COMMISSIONER VARNEY LOWENTHAL.
AND HARDER COMMISSIONER FRANK
KALONA VOICE SERVED ON CITY
COUNCIL WITH MANY YEARS AND
FORMER FEDERAL MARITIME
COMMISSION CHAIR AND CURRENT
PORT OF LONG BEACH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. MISTER MARIO CORNER
PLEASE WELCOME THEM
WE ARE MOVING BACK IN. FILE
ORDERED MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ
ITEM ONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO SEEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO VOTER
REGISTRATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I THIS
IT MEASURES BACK ON CONCURRENCE
FROM THE SENATE WITH TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THIS ESSENTIALLY
CREATES AN AUTOMATIC. VOTER READ
PREREGISTRATION FOR MINOR
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
MIR'S TO POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA
AUTOMATIC VOTER REG. IN PRE
REGISTRATION FOR SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS HOPING TO
INCREASE VOTER PARTICIPATION IN
CALIFORNIA ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MADAM
CLERK WILL YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY
TWO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SEVEN ACR ONE
SEVENTY METACARPALS READ.
RIGHT I ACR ONE FORTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU.
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION.
I RISE TODAY TO INTRODUCE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY THREE. TO DECLARE
FEBRUARY NINETEENTH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ON FEBRUARY NINETEENTH NINETEEN
FORTY TWO.
TWO MONTHS AFTER JAPAN'S BOMBING
OF PEARL HARBOR.
PRESIDENT FRANKLIN ROOSEVELT
SIGNED EXECUTIVE ORDER NINE OH
SIX SIX.
WHICH LED TO THE MASS
INCARCERATION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
AMERICANS OF JAPANESE ANCESTRY.
SOLELY.
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR ANCESTRY.
WITHOUT ANY DUE PROCESS OF LAW.
AND WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE
TREASON OR MILITARY NECESSITY.
THEY WERE INCARCERATED BEHIND
BARBED WIRES.
AND TEN CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
LOCATED IN ISOLATED LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
INCLUDING TWO IN CALIFORNIA.
MANZANAR INTO A LAKE.
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINE TWO SIX SIX
DESTROYED KALLUS AMERICAN
DREAMS.
THEY LOST THEIR HOMES THEIR JOBS
THERE FARMS AND BUSINESSES. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THEIR FREEDOM AND DIGNITY.
DESPITE THIS MASSIVE AND JUSTICE
OVER THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
JAPANESE AMERICANS VOLUNTEERED
TO FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY. ON THE
BATTLEFIELDS OF EUROPE AND THE
PACIFIC.
TO FIGHT FOR THE FREEDOMS NEVER
BEING DENIED TO THEIR LOVED
ONES.
PROVE THEIR LOYALTY TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THESE JAPANESE AMERICAN SOLDIERS
SERVED IN SEGREGATED MILITARY
UNITS
WHICH BECAME AMONG THE MOST
DECORATED IN AMERICAN MILITARY
HISTORY.
TWENTY ONE RECEIVED A MEDAL OF
HONOR THE NATION'S HIGHEST
MILITARY DECORATION AND FIFTY TO
RECEIVE THE DISTINGUISHED
SERVICE CROSS.
THIRTY YEARS AGO.
A MEASURE OF JUSTICE WITH
SHAVED.
WHEN PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN
SIGNED THE CIVIL LIBERTIES ACT
OF NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND
ISSUED AN OFFICIAL APOLOGY
APOLOGY.
ON BEHALF OF OUR NATION.
DECLARING THAT THE MASS
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS WITH BECAUSE BY RACE
PRESIDENT'S.
WARTIME HYSTERIA AND THE FAILURE
OF POLITICAL LEADERSHIP.
MEMBERS WE MUST REMEMBER THIS
HISTORY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
NOT REPEAT IT.
TODAY WE ARE BEARING WITNESS TO
PRESIDENTIAL EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
TARGETING MUSLIM IMMIGRANTS
AS NATIONAL SECURITY THREATS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE FOR
MORE PERFECT UNION WE MUST
CONTINUE TO REMAIN VIGILANT.
AND THAT IS WHY I ASKED YOU TO
JOIN ME IN REMEMBERING THIS DAY
IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY.
I ASK FOR YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE AYE IN SUPPORT OF
HR ONE FORTY THREE AND THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE AYE ON
ITS INTRODUCTION. AS.
HE SO RIGHTFULLY STATED THAT I
IN INJUSTICE OCCURRED WITH THE
INCARCERATION IN INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS
THAT SIDE. THAT THIS IS SOME
THAT WE MUST REMEMBER. AND. IT
REMINDS ME OF A QUOTE FROM THIS
JEWISH HISTORIAN PROFESSOR
YOU'RE SUPPLYING YOU SHOW ME.
THAT HE SAID THE ANTONYM OF
FORGETTING.
IS NOT REMEMBERING.
BUT JUSTICE.
AND WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE TALKED ABOUT THE
APOLOGY THAT WAS MADE.
BY PRESIDENT REAGAN THAT THAT
THAT THERE IS JUSTICE BEING
SERVED THERE BUT THERE IS ALSO
JUSTICE FINALLY SERVED. WHEN
KOREMATSU CONVICTION WAS
OVERTURNED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE AS AMERICANS WE CANNOT
DENY OUR INVOLVEMENT IN ONE OF
THESE SHAMEFUL AYE HISTORICAL
EVENTS THAT TOOK PLACE IN OUR
COUNTRY WE MUST COMMIT OURSELVES
NEVER TO REPEAT. THAT MISTAKE
IRIS OUT ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FORTY THREE. AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE FOR
BRING IT FORWARD.
YOU HEARD FROM OUR COLLEAGUES
THE INJUSTICES.
THAT MANY JAPANESE AMERICANS
HAVE EXPERIENCE IN SPITE OF
THEIR GREAT LOYALTY TO OUR
NATION.
IT REMINDS ME OF A QUOTE.
FROM THE REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
THAT INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A
THREAT TO JUSTICE.
EVERYWHERE.
MY REMARKS TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS.
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ARE ALL
CONNECTED IN THAT WE MUST STAND
UP IN THE FACE. OF ANY
INJUSTICE.
LESS.
LET US NEVER FORGET.
LESS WE WILL REPEAT THE MISTAKES
OF HISTORY.
I'M ALSO REMINDED OF OUR VISIT
TO THIS ASSEMBLY FLOOR LAST YEAR
BY KAREN KOREMATSU.
THE DAUGHTER FRED KOREMATSU.
WHO CONTINUES A LEGACY OF HER
FATHER AND HAS CREATED A
FOUNDATION? THAT TALKS ABOUT
INJUSTICE AND HOW WE MUST WORK
TOGETHER ACROSS RACIAL GROUPS
AND CULTURAL GROUPS AND
CONTINUE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT PREJUDICE HAS
NO PLACE IN OUR NATION.
I AM VERY PROUD TO BE IN A
COMMUNITY. UP THAT HAS RECEIVED
THE BENEFIT OF MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS THE CITY OF RICHMOND.
THE CITIES OF EL SERENO.
HAVE HISTORIC CONTRIBUTIONS
AND I'M PROUD TO BE A PART OF A
COMMUNITY THAT RECENTLY RENAMED
OUR ONE OF OUR MIDDLE SCHOOLS.
AFTER FRED KOREMATSU INCREDIBLY
A DAD OF A GRADUATE OF FRED
KOREMATSU MIDDLE SCHOOL. A LET
US CONTINUE IN THE TRADITION OF
RECOGNIZING.
THE STRUGGLES OF GROUPS.
AND OUR SHARED HUMANITY.
AND THANK THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
NOT JUST TO WIN OR TO.
BUT TO MAKE THIS A GREAT NATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR ONE FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MEN'S BIGGER.
TODAY IBM I RISE ON THE HAVE LET
YOU KNOW CAUCUS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY THREE.
TODAY WE REMEMBER THE
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
WE ALSO REMEMBER IT AS A DARK
AND SHAMEFUL CHAPTER IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY.
AND OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
IT'S TOOK PART IN THIS
DEMORALIZING TRAGEDY.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE DAY THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
WHAT THEY'VE THE COUNTRY SO THAT
THEY MADE NOT ONLY THE LOS
ANGELES?
WHICH I REPRESENT.
BUT ALSO CALIFORNIA.
THEN I STAND BEFORE YOU.
PROUD OF THAT LITTLE TOKYO THE
LITTLE TOKYO DISTRICT.
I THAT I REPRESENT.
THAT IS BEEN AND THAT IS BEEN.
ACTIVE FOR OVER A CENTURY
AND IS HOME TO ONE OF LARGEST
JAPANESE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
TODAY WE ALSO RECOGNIZE.
THAT IT IS ONE OF THE ONLY WILL
ONLY THREE JAPANESE UPTOWN'S.
AND IT WAS MADE A QUARTER
DESTINATION POINT.
I IN CALIFORNIA.
I BY OUR COLLEAGUE IN SANTA
MONICA.
A FEW YEARS AGO.
SO WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
REMEMBER.
AND WE WANT TO CREATE AWARENESS
SO THAT WE ENSURE THAT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER.
IT'S THINK YOU BETTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY THREE.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMEMBER.
AND THAT WE MARK THIS THIS WAS
A A VERY DARK TIME.
IN OUR HISTORY.
IN THE REASON WHY WE NEED TO
REMEMBER THE DARK TIMES IN OUR
HISTORY IS SO THAT WE. DON'T
REPEAT THEM AND.
I ALSO WANT TO RISE ON BEHALF OF
YOU KNOW. MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS.
WHO?
?
WERE TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES TAKEN AWAY FROM THEIR
PROPERTY.
FARMERS IN MY DISTRICT AND THEY
WERE AMERICANS.
YEAH A LOT OF TIMES WE TALK
ABOUT JAPANESE AMERICANS THEY
WERE AMERICANS.
HOOD CALLED THIS.
COUNTRY THEIR HOME.
HAD ESTABLISH FORMS VERY
PROSPEROUS FORMS IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
ONLY TO BE TOLD YOU YOU NEED TO
BE RELOCATED AND TAKEN TO PLACES
LIKE TULE LAKE.
.
AND JUST THE COMPLETE INJUSTICE
OF THAT.
IT ALSO REMINDS US THAT.
HYSTERIA IS NOT A GOOD THING.
AND THAT SOMETIMES OUT OF FEAR
AND OUT OF MASS HYSTERIA WE CAN
DO INCREDIBLY TERRIBLE AND AWFUL
THINGS TO OUR FELLOW. HUMAN
BEINGS LESSON WE SHOULD ALWAYS.
REMIND OURSELVES OF.
AND SO YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
MY CONSTITUENTS WHO AND YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A.
THERE ARE SOME REALLY TERRIBLE
STORIES ABOUT.
FARMS ARE ULTIMATELY SPLIT UP
AND NOTHING TO COME BACK TO.
THERE'S ALSO SOME REALLY AMAZING
STORIES OF.
A PEOPLE WHO TOOK CARE OF THOSE
FARMS AND ENSURE THAT THEY.
WERE STEWARDED AND RESTORED
BACK.
TO THEIR RIGHTFUL OWNERS WHEN
THEY CAME BACK.
IT SO I RISE. ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WHO WHO WENT TO
THAT AND WHO CAN DO IT.
BUT ULTIMATELY CAME BACK TO
THOSE FARMS AND.
AND.
.
AND PROSPERED INTO THE FUTURE
YOU KNOW BIG.
BOTH BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN.
INDIVIDUAL DETERMINATION BUT
ALSO WITH THE HELP OF THEIR
FELLOW MEN.
AND WOMEN AND SO ARE BY RISE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT TO REMEMBER IT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MAN SPEAKER I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
TO A URGES STRONG AYE VOTE FOR
ACR. ONE FORTY THREE A LIKE MANY
OF US WHO COME FROM AGRICULTURAL
DISTRICTS AYE TO NEW MANY
FAMILIES WHO.
WHO WERE JUST TAKEN AWAY IT
MIGHT MY PARENTS TOLD STORIES OF
OF PEOPLE THEY HAD KNOWN AND
THAT OTHER NEIGHBORS WOULD WORK
THEIR FARMS FOR THEM AND
SOMETIMES THAT WORKED OUT?
SOMETIMES IT DIDN'T.
I HAD THE HONOR OF A BILL
AWHILE A HOSPICE SOCIAL WORKER
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY GOING TO
MANY FAMILIES HOMES AND
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES WILL USE
HOSPICE IT. SOME MORE SOME LESS
AND MY EXPERIENCE WAS JAPANESE
FAMILIES WERE BIG HOSPICE USERS
THEY HAD VERY. A. KEY FAMILY
STRUCTURE THAT THAT WELCOMED.
WITH WELCOME DEATH INTO THEIR
HOME AND JUST REMEMBER ONE WOMAN
I HAD WAS A HUNDRED YEARS OLD
STILL CHOPPING BAMBOO IN BED.
AGENDAS THE FAMILY GATHERED
AROUND A EVERYBODY BUT
REGARDLESS OF THE HOMES I WENT
TO A MOSTLY ALWAYS WOMEN
CARETAKERS WOMEN WOMEN WOMEN
DOING THAT WITH THE WORK OF
CARING FOR THE FAMILY AND
KEEPING TRADITIONS ALIVE.
BUT EVERYBODY WOULD HAVE A
PICTURE OF THE CAMP UP ON THE
WALL AND THEN LIKE OUR PRAYER WE
HEARD EARLIER I OFTEN WONDERED
WHY WHY WOULD THE. THE
THE PICTURE OF THE CAN'T BE UP
ON THE WALL LIKE A CELEBRATION.
AND EVERY WOULD WOULD POINT TO
IT BECAUSE IT JUST BEEN
INTEGRATED INTO THE INTO THEIR
THEIR FAMILY AND THEIR NARRATIVE
AND THEIR.
STORIES AND IT WASN'T UP OF A
PERIOD OF BEING ANGRY AND SAD
BUT JUST A BOOK POOR LIKE WE
HAVE SURVIVED SO MUCH AND HERE
WE ARE AND LOOK AT OUR FAMILY
WAS HERE AND LOOK AT. HOW SO AND
SO LOOK WHEN THEY WERE LITTLE
AND NOW HERE THEY ARE IN? A
DYING SO I JUST THINK THAT THE
HISTORY IS ALL AROUND US AND WE
JUST HAVE TO BE OPEN TO TO
SEEING IT INTO A FEELING AT. A
AND TO PAYING HONOR A TO THOSE
WHO HAVE COME BEFORE US AND
CONTINUE TO LIVE ON WITH THAT
LEGACY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE NAY C. ARE ONE FORTY
THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAVIAR
ON YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO SPEAK.
OF A THEFT OF LIFE LIBERTY THAT
WAS HORRIFYING SEVENTY SIX YEARS
AGO AND REMAINS TERRIBLE TO THIS
DAY.
IN FEBRUARY OF NINETEEN FORTY
TWO WHEN THE NAME OF SECURITY.
MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN WERE
ORDERED OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
AND INTO PRISON CAMPS.
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THEIR ETHNIC
BACKGROUND.
GRIPPED BY PARANOIA AND RACIAL
BIGOTRY THE GOVERNMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES STOLE THE
LIVES AND LIVELIHOODS OF OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
TWO THIRDS OF WHOM ARE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
POSTERS.
READING.
INSTRUCTIONS TO ALL PERSONS OF
JAPANESE ANCESTRY.
WERE PLACED ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
AND ALL AROUND THE FIFTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
WHEN YOU GOOGLE MAPS THAT WHEN
YOU GOOGLE IMAGES I'M SORRY.
THERE IS A GLARING IMAGE THAT
STANDS OUT OF A SIGN THAT READS.
JAPS KEEP MOVING.
THIS IS THE WHITE MAN'S
NEIGHBORHOOD.
OUR SHARED AMERICAN HISTORY IS
RIDDLED WITH INJUSTICE AND
EVENTS THAT LOOKING BACK.
I NEW GENERATION OF AMERICANS
CAN ONLY THINK.
WHAT WERE THE THINKING
HOW COULD THEY DO THIS?
THE RHETORIC OF THEN. IT'S NO
DIFFERENT THAN THE RHETORIC OF
TODAY.
MUCH OF WHAT WE HEAR AGAINST
IMMIGRANTS DREAMERS UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES MUSLIMS LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
ALL OF WHOM CAN HAVE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS.
BUT IN WHAT IS TODAY'S RHETORIC
WE MUST LEARN FROM THE PAST.
WE MUST BE ON GUARD WHEN OUR
GOVERNMENT SEEKS IT TAKE AWAY
THE FREEDOM OF ANY PERSON.
WHETHER THERE A CITIZEN OF THE
UNITED STATES ARE NOT.
I COMMEND MY COLLEAGUES.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
A FOR KEEPING THE MEMORY OF THIS
TRAGEDY. ALIVE SO THAT WE MAY
NEVER FORGET ITS LESSONS.
OR THE PEOPLE
WHO SUFFER FROM IT.
IN ORDER TO NO. WHERE THE FUTURE
OF THIS NATION GOES?
WE MUST ALWAYS REMEMBER OUR
HISTORY.
AND WHERE WE COME FROM.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY COOLEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS.
COMMEMORATIVE DARK PERIOD IN OUR
HISTORY AND I'M MORE. RISAN
HONOR OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WE ACTUALLY
HAD AN ASSEMBLY CENTER. THE WILL
LURK ASSEMBLY CENTER WHICH WAS
UP IN NORTHEAST SACRAMENTO
COUNTY.
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE
COMMEMORATED AT WELL LURKER
PARK.
IN RECENT YEARS THE SUNRISE
RECREATION PARK DISTRICT HAS
DONE A COMPLETE REVAMP OF THIS
MONUMENT AT THEIR WILL ORDER
PARK. REPLANTED THE CHERRY. OF
TREES.
IN A COMMEMORATIVE GARDEN
REDOING THE SIGNAGE.
DOING OVERALL UPGRADE TO JUST
KEEP THIS MEMORY ALIVE IN THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NO DOUBT THAT
ASSEMBLY CENTER SERVICE.
A BROAD REACH INTERIOR WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE PERSONS OF.
.
MR MY COLLEAGUE FROM NECKLACES
AREA FEDERAL BRING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE AND WE LIKE THE FIRST ROLE
OPEN FOR COFFERS YES I WOULD
LIKE TO FIRST OF ALL THANK. ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR STANDING UP
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION I
ASK FOR THE FIRST RECALL. A CO
AUTHORS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I'VE OF.
THANK YOU FOR CLERK WILL PLEASE
OPEN THE RUN.
MEMBERS FIRST ROLE IS OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THIS RULES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS RULE IS OPEN FOR COOPERS.
MCCARTHY'S CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MISTER
MAYOR SUCI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS.
FIRST WE HAVE TWO SURVIVORS.
FROM THE JEROME AND ROAR CAMPS
AND THE TO A LAKE.
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
THEY ARE PART OF A SPECIAL
PROJECT WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE EVERYONE. UPON OF GERMAN
A SESSION TODAY IN ROOM THREE
SEVENTEEN ESPECIALLY VENTURA
MORE ABOUT THE TUNA CANYON
DETENTION CENTER. WHICH IS A
VERY.
AMAZING.
BUT LESSER KNOWN PART OF THIS
HISTORY OF THIS PERIOD IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY. WHERE THERE
ARE NOT ONLY JAPANESE IMMIGRANTS
BUT ALSO? GERMAN AND ITALIAN
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE ROUND UP.
AT THE SAME AND HELD
INCARCERATED THE SAME DETENTION
CENTER THIS TUNA CANNING
DETENTION CENTER. AS NATIONAL
SECURITY PHILLIP THREATS I LIKE
TO INTRODUCE A RETIRED AIR IS
AEROSPACE ENGINEER AND FORMER.
CANCER HARM FROM JAROMIR OUR
DOCTOR CONSCIOUS SAHARA AND A
FORMER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL INTO A LAKE CAMP
SURVIVOR NANCY ODA
MEMBERS WE HAVE A FORMER
COLLEAGUE VISITING US TODAY
PLEASE WELCOME FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHARE. OF SHANNON
GROWTH.
I DIDN'T EIGHT TEN AND ELEVEN
WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWELVE S. C. R.
SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR JACKSON
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
CONVENTION OF THE ELIMINATION OF
ALL FORMS OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES SCR SEVENTY
EIGHT. URGES OUR STATE TO
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PRINCIPLES UNDERLYING THE
CONVENTION ON THE ELIMINATION OF
ALL FORMS OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST WOMEN. OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS C. DOT.
SETO WAS A TREATY THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE UNITED NATIONS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. KNOWN AS
AN INTERNATIONAL BILL OF RIGHTS
FOR WOMEN THE ONLY INTERNATIONAL
DOCUMENT THEY COMPREHENSIVELY
ADDRESSES WOMEN'S RIGHTS WITH
REGARD TO THE ECONOMY. EDUCATION
HEALTH CARE PUBLIC SAFETY AND
OTHER ASPECTS OF CIVIL SOCIETY.
SINCE THEN THIS TREATY HAS BEEN
ADOPTED BY A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN COUNTRIES. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE UNITED STATES
IS ONE OF ONLY SEVEN NATION
STATES THAT HAVE NOT RATIFIED
THE TREATY.
THE OTHERS BEING IRAN SOMALIA
SUDAN THE VATICAN AND THE
PACIFIC ISLAND NATIONS OF TONGA
AND PALAU.
I AM A PRINCE WILL CO AUTHOR OF
THIS S. YARD BECAUSE MY CITY. IN
THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES WAS
THE FIRST TO PASS A LOCAL
ORDINANCE TO IMPLEMENT SEAT OUR
PRINCIPLES
FOLLOWED BY LOS ANGELES AND NOW
OVER SIXTY CITIES. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN OUR COUNTRY.
LAST YEAR LEADERS FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ASK ME TO INTRODUCE
THIS RESOLUTION TO URGE SEE
DOLLARS PRINCIPLES TO BE ADOPTED
STATEWIDE. WHICH I WAS HAPPY TO
DO ALONGSIDE THIS S. C. ARE
SENATE AUTHOR WHOSE CHAMPION
THIS ISSUE FOR YEARS.
WHILE OUR STATE HAS BEEN A
NATIONAL LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO
EQUAL RIGHTS FOR WOMEN. WE DON'T
KNOW THERE'S MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE. ONE WOMAN CONTINUE TO BE
PAID LESS THAN MEN THROUGHOUT
THE ECONOMY. WHEN THERE'S NOT
GENDER PARITY IN THE BOARD ROOM
OR IN THE LEGISLATURE. WHEN
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN IS STILL
WAY TOO PREVALENT.
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
RESOLUTION WAS INTRODUCED BEFORE
THE ME TOO AND WE SAID ENOUGH
MOVEMENTS BUT OBVIOUSLY OUR
STATE HAS A LONG WAY TO GO.
THIS RESOLUTION IS A FIRST STEP.
THREAT WE SEEK TO RAISE
AWARENESS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
SEED ON WHAT IT IS MEANT ON THE
LIVES OF WOMEN AND YOUNG GIRLS.
IN THE MEMBER COUNTRIES HAVE
ADOPTED THIS TREATY.
WE ALL HOPE THAT SOMEDAY OUR
COUNTRY WILL TAKE THIS STEP BUT
UNTIL THEN WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO LEAD ON THIS EFFORT AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
THIS RESOLUTION IS PASSED THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND WITHOUT A SINGLE NO VOTE.
MADAM SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE OPEN THE FIRST ROLE FOR
CO AUTHORS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE ITEM.
AS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE THERE ARE FIFTY EIGHT
COAUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSE.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM THIRTEEN AS
HE ARE FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED AERO.
SO MEMBER COBB EUROPE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR S. C.
R. FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR CANNELLA. WHICH HONORS
THE LIVES OF FIVE ARMY VETERANS
FROM MONTEREY COUNTY THROUGH
HIGHWAY DESIGNATIONS THE
AMENDMENTS FIX MISSPELLINGS AND
DESIGNATIONS TO ABIDE BY BY DMB
REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'LL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM ALL THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
AMENDMENTS THE RESOLUTION ARE
ADOPTED.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM
AND ACTUALLY TO EVIDENCE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT. ALL THOSE VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WHERE NOW MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY IN MEMORY.
MISTER BONTA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR MISTER MULLINS DESK.
THANK YOU. MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS
CHAIR. OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RISE.
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF THE
HONORABLE MARCH FONG YOU.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT
THE AGE OF NINETY FIVE?
DOCTOR MARCH FONG YOU WAS QUITE
SIMPLY.
AND I CON.
A TRAILBLAZER IN CALIFORNIA
POLITICS AND A LEGEND.
IN THE API.
COMMUNITY.
MARCH FONG YOU WAS BORN ON MARCH
TWENTY NINTH NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO.
TO HAWAII UN KONG AND.
SHE SHUI JEW IN THE SMALL
CENTRAL VALLEY TOWN OF OAKDALE
CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS A THIRD.
GENERATION CALIFORNIAN AND HER
PARENTS
OWNED A HAND WASH LAUNDRY
BUSINESS.
SHE OFTEN TOLD CONSTITUENTS SHE
WAS.
BORN BEHIND A CHINESE LAUNDRY.
HER HUMBLE BEGINNINGS DID NOT
HINDER HER. FROM BECOMING AN
ACCOMPLISHED AN ACTIVE STUDENT
INVOLVED IN STUDENT GOVERNMENT.
HONOR SOCIETY CHEERLEADING.
AND TENNIS.
AFTER BEING TOLD BY A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR.
THAT SHE WOULD NOT BE HIRED AS A
SCIENTIST BECAUSE SHE WAS
CHINESE.
SHE PERSISTED.
A GRADUATE FROM UC BERKELEY
MILLS COLLEGE AND STANFORD MARCH
FONG YOU MADE WAVES AS A DENTAL
HYGIENIST AND DEFIED STEREOTYPES
AND PREJUDICE TO BECOME THE
FIRST WOMAN. AND FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN TO CHAIR YOU SEE SAN
FRANCISCO'S DEPARTMENT OF DENTAL
HYGIENE.
THE FIRST AT THE HYGIENIST
FOR OAKLAND PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY SCHOOLS AND
PRESIDENT.
OF THE AMERICAN DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION.
FROM NINETEEN FORTY FOUR.
THE NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN.
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
SHE WAS ELECTED TO THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND THEN.
HERE TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY.
WHERE SHE BECAME CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN
LEGISLATOR AND FIRST CHINESE
AMERICAN?
TO SERVE IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
DOCTOR YOU ABLY AND DUTIFULLY
REPRESENTED OAKLAND.
AND CASTRO VALLEY FROM NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX.
UNTIL NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MARCH
FONG YOU WAS ELECTED CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE.
BECOMING THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN TO BE ELECTED TO
A CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AFTER FOUR TERMS A SECRETARY OF
STATE
SHE ACCEPTED AN APPOINTMENT.
BY PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON.
SERVE AS THE US AMBASSADOR.
TO THE FEDERAL STATES OF
MICRONESIA.
MARCH FONG YOU WAS AN ICONIC
TRAILBLAZER FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS
AND THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE
SHE REMAINS A COMMITTED ADVOCATE
FOR EDUCATION.
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
DENTAL HEALTH CONSUMER RIGHTS.
AND THE PRESERVATION
OF CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA'S
RICH HISTORY.
DR.
YOU WAS INTEGRAL TO THE CUT
CONSTRUCTION OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE COMPLEX HERE.
IN SACRAMENTO AND THE BUILDING
WILL BE RENAMED.
IN HER HONOR.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANT. MARCH FONG YOU
WAS A WOMAN A FAMILY.
AND OF HEART.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER STEP
CHILDREN.
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN.
ONE GREAT GRANDCHILD AND HER
DAUGHTER SU YEN AND HER HUSBAND
JIM.
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN.
IN HONOR AND AND SINCERE
GRATITUDE.
TO THE HONORABLE MARCH FONG YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I. THINK YOU AND SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS TO ALSO PAY TRIBUTE. TO
MARCH AMONG YOU A IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX WE LIVED IN IN CASTRO
VALLEY AND I WHILE I WAS A YOUNG
PERSON THEN. I DISTINCTLY
REMEMBER.
THE PRIDE OF MY MOTHER A FIRST
GENERATION A CALIFORNIA AN
AMERICAN.
WHO WAS SO EXCITED TO VOTE FOR
THE FIRST WOMAN AT TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT HER AT THAT LEVEL?
SHE WAS ACTIVE SOMEONE IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
BUT I JUST REMEMBER EVEN AS A
AS A CHILD THAT THE PRIDE THAT
SHE FELT AND WHAT A.
GLASS CEILING IT FELT LIKE IT
WAS BURST FOR EVERYBODY AND
CERTAINLY GAVE HOPE TO SOMEBODY
LIKE ME THAT TIME MY MOM SAID
MARCH ONE YOU CAN DO IT ANYBODY
CAN DO IT. A AND SO JUST AS THE
TRAILBLAZER IT SHE WAS ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I WANT TO
THANK HER FOR HER SERVICE TO HER
FAMILY STOP FOR THAT SACRIFICE I
KNOW THAT THEY PAID FOR ANYONE
IN PUBLIC SERVICE. ENDERS.
AND JUST OF TORRENT TO NOT LET
THIS MOMENT GO WITHOUT SAYING
THE SIGNIFICANCE THAT SHE PLAYED
IN MANY OF OUR LIVES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MADAM%
SPEAKER I ALSO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY TO JOIN IN A
MEMORY. OF THE HONORABLE MUCH
FONG YOU THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN AND WOMEN ELECTED TO
SERVE AS CALIFORNIA SECRETARY
STATE.
AND SHE DID SO FOR NEARLY TWO
DECADES US WAS ALSO THE FIRST TO
ME ASIAN AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE
STATE WHY CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICE
IN A COUNTRY.
TALK TO YOU TOOK EVERYONE BY
SURPRISE WHEN SHE ENTERED THE
POLITICAL SCENE IN THE NINETEEN
FIFTIES.
WHEN SHE WAS SELECTED TO THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION.
THIS WAS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IN
A NINETEEN FIFTIES THERE WERE NO
ASIAN AMERICANS HOLDING LOCAL OR
STATEWIDE OFFICE.
MARCH WAS A TRAILBLAZER AND
SOMEONE WHO CHALLENGE THE STATUS
QUO.
HER HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELOR TOLD
HER TO GIVE UP HER DREAM OF
BECOMING A TEACHER BECAUSE NO
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD HIRE A
CHINESE WOMAN.
WHEN THERE WERE NO WOMEN ROLE
MODELS FOR HER TO LOOK UP TO.
SHE DECIDED TO BECOME ONE
HERSELF.
MARCH ENTERED EARNED A
REPUTATION THROUGH HAVE FIGHTS
AGAINST.
CIVIL INJUSTICES AND
DISCRIMINATION DESPITE BEING ONE
OF THE FEW MINORITY WOMEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
WHERE SHE OFTEN FACE PREJUDICE
AND SEXISM SHE SPOKE OUT AGAINST
THE UNFAIR TREATMENT OF WOMEN
AND TO ADVOCATE FOR REPRODUCTIVE
AND EQUAL RIGHTS?
MARCH ALSO TOOK ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF REPRESENTING
ASIAN AMERICANS.
AND SERVED AS A VOICE FOR WOMEN.
DESPITE THE CONSTANT SCRUTINY
AND DISCRIMINATION SHE WAS
FEARLESS.
SHE WON SAID THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THE DECK HAS BEEN STACKED
AGAINST WOMEN WITH RESPECT TO
POLITICAL ACCESS.
AS ACTIVE AND INVOLVED AMERICANS
OF ASIAN DESCENT.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
OURSELVES.
AND TO AMERICA TO PROVE ONCE AND
FOR ALL THAT THE AMERICAN DREAM
IS NOT RESTRICTED TO ANYONE RACE
CLASS CULTURE OR GENDER.
IT BELONGS TO ALL OF THIS AND WE
MUST TAKE UP THE CHALLENGE OF
MAKING THIS A SAFER MORE HUMANE
MORE RESPONSIVE MORE ACCOUNTABLE
IN MY CHEST SOCIETY.
MUCH REMAINS ONE OF THE MOST
NOTABLE RECOGNIZED AND
CELEBRATED ASIAN AMERICAN WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA POLITICS.
WHO OPENED THE DOOR TO ASIAN
AMERICANS AND WOMEN IN PUBLIC
SERVICE?
I HAD THE HONOR OF ATTENDING HER
MEMORIAL SERVICE HELD IN OAKLAND
THIS PAST JANUARY.
WHERE HER FORMER COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST PROMINENT POLITICAL
FIGURES?
SHARE STORIES ABOUT HER. I ALSO
SPOKE WITH SOME OF THEM WHO GAVE
THEIR HIGHEST REGARDS AND PLACES
TO MARCH.
THEIR STORIES DEMONSTRATED THE
QUALITY OF HER CRYING KINDNESS
AND YET TENACIOUS CHARACTER.
WE MUST CONTINUE HER LEGACY
THROUGH A PUBLIC SERVICE
AND CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
RACIAL IN. OUR ACT.
EQUALITY.
AND GENDER DIVERSITY THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME
TO RISE.
IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT A MEMORIAL RESOLUTION TO
DR. USE FAMILY HER DAUGHTER SOO
YEON STEIN AND HER GRANDSON A
LYRIC ARE WITH US TODAY AS WELL
AS DOCTOR USE FORMER
SPOKESPERSON KAREN. LOCAL
MARCIANO AND KAREN'S HUSBAND
BRUCE
.
MEMBERS A SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIRST CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SITTING IN HERE
THEIR NOTE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND AT NINE
A. M..
THE QUORUM CALLS LIFTED